okay if you're a regular viewer of what
if you know we've already explored the
idea of finding silicon-based alien life
but what if we didn't have to venture
far off into the universe to find these
life forms
what if you were the one made of silicon
instead of carbon
how would silicon-based life have
evolved
what would your new human body be like
and how different would earth need to be
for a silicon version of you to exist
this is what if and here's what would
happen if humans were silicon based
instead of carbon-based
carbon is a bit of an attention hog and
for good reason
all life on our planet shares carbon as
its primary building block
18
of your body is made of carbon
without it you'd have no dna
on the other hand silicon is one of the
most abundant elements on earth
second only to oxygen
approximately 25 to 30 percent of our
planet's crust is made up of the stuff
the potential for silicon-based life was
first suggested in 1891
by astronomer julius chyna
the hypothesis is based on the chemical
similarities between carbon and silicon
both elements bond with oxygen to form
polymers
in other words large molecular
structures
however when silicon reacts with oxygen
on earth it forms silicon dioxide
this solid also known as silica is a key
ingredient in sand
and less naturally silicon and oxygen
can be found together in the synthetic
compound known as silicone
this liquid or rubbery substance is in
everything from electronics to oven
mitts
not to mention breast implants
but these silicon-based compounds can't
support life
unless you're talking about the what-if
universe
even though they have a lot of chemical
similarities if human life was based on
silicon instead of carbon
everything would be different
while both elements are able to form
double bonds with oxygen the bonds
formed by silicon are typically weaker
that means silicon-based life on earth
would be simple and primitive
there's no way that your body in its
current complex form of organs bones and
tissues could exist
yeah say goodbye to the human shape as
you know it you'd now be a blob of
silicon compounds
and not just humans
every living thing on earth would likely
be some kind of blob too
it would actually be a miracle that
you'd exist at all
it would also be highly unlikely for a
simple life form like you to be able to
successfully reproduce you'd be too
fragile
this would be especially important when
thinking about how this silicon-based
life would have begun on earth in the
first place
chemical life needs to exist in a medium
that lets molecules move around
for carbon liquid water is the perfect
medium
water can carry things into and out of
the cell
but water wouldn't support the
development of your new human chemistry
the double bonds of silicon would break
down into single bonds in the presence
of h2o
that means instead of evolving into the
stellar example of flesh and bone that
you are today
you'd turn into a silicate rock
silicon-based life would need a
different liquid to be the common
binding element of life
one medium that could work is sulfuric
acid
that's because the silicon structures
that normally break down in water would
be more stable in sulfuric acid
the implications of this would go far
beyond every life form on earth being
completely different
now the whole planet would be different
too
not only would life need oceans of
sulfuric acid to spring out of
the atmosphere would need a major
overhaul
silicon-based life wouldn't necessarily
need oxygen
because silicon would react with oxygen
the same way it would react with water
it would turn into a rock
temperatures on earth would also have to
change dramatically
made from silicon you'd need an
extremely warm environment in order to
thrive and by extremely warm i mean
unbearably hot
the melting point of silicon is
1410 degrees
yeah in other words for this element to
exist in any form other than a solid
earth would have to be a very toasty
very acidic place
and scattered across it would be
billions of blobs of life completely
incapable of reproducing
now the odds of these blobs evolving
into intelligent life like the carbon
you
well sorry to say but it appears we've
wandered into science fiction territory
imagining the possibility of
silicon-based earthlings
raises many big questions
like how did life begin on our planet
and what conditions are necessary for
life to continue to evolve
but also what would happen if things
went in a different direction
well whatever the answers to those
questions may be
life flourished here on earth the way it
did and it was the perfect carbon-based
recipe for you to become the human you
are
and who knows
maybe life didn't really originate here
on earth after all
wait what well
that sounds like a story
for another
what if
you